soirée le ps qui continue grand débat
politique à suivre avant de vous
présenter nos prochains invités revenons
donc en détails sur les résultats
lr et ps qui semble donc en bonne
position pour garder leurs bastions les
électeurs ont semble-t-il privilégiez
donc les présidents sortants même s'il
peut y avoir encore des surprises vont
me le disiez tout à l'heure
est ce à dire que ce qu'on a appelé
l'ancien monde a encore de beaux jours
devant lui c'est toute la question qu'on
va se poser avec nos invités d'abord les
explications de cécile 6o ce matin les l
air affiche une mine réjouie
à l'exception de la région paca où
renaud muselier devancé de quelques
points par thierry mariani hervé morin
jean rottner christelle mourant c'est
valérie pécresse xavier bertrand et
laurent wauquiez les six autres
présidents de région sortants sont
arrivés en tête au premier tour
un soulagement pour christian jacob le
chef du parti
vous avez expliqué à longueur d'antenne
et de
édito des uns et des autres que l air
étaient explosées déchiré entre d'un
côté le front national de l'autre côté
monsieur macron que c'était la
présidentielle avant l'heure et c'est
qu'on n'existerait plus pour un parti
qui n'existe plus vous invite à regarder
les résultats on aime surprise du côté
socialiste françois bonneau loïg
chesnais-girard marie-guite dufay carole
delga et alain rousset les cinq
présidents actuels que l'on disait en
danger face aux divisions de la gauche
et à la montée du et rennes ont résisté
mais s'est passé quelque chose ça n'est
pas un sondage c'est un vote et dans ce
vote
il est apparu quelque chose qui apparaît
c'est invraisemblable jusqu'ici mais
nous ne sommes pas condamnés à vivre le
duel entre et emmanuel macron et marine
le pen l'année prochaine avec ses
résultats inattendus
la gauche et la droite se voit bien
jouer les trouble fête dans le combat
annoncé pour la présidentielle entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron pas si
sûr pour stanislas guerrini délégué
général de l hérault m je crois que les
résultats qu'on a vue constaté hier ne
permettent pas de redire cette image
droite gauche c'est les partis qui sont
déjà implantés qui ont des sortants et
puis les partis qui le sont moins et
c'est le cas pour la majorité
présentielle pour le rn les partis
traditionnels n'ont fait que profité de
l'abstention de ses électeurs
le vote est quelque chose de sérieux et
qu'ils ne vont pas voter
mais ils prennent le risque tout
simplement de favoriser leurs
adversaires ceux là même que toute
l'année ils ne voudraient pas voir aux
affaires pour le second tour le
rassemblement national appelle ses
électeurs aux urnes et mise sur un
sursaut de la participation pour espérer
gagner une région est avec nous pour la
deuxième partie de cette édition
spéciale d' allons plus loin françois
patriat bonsoir sénateur de la côte-d'or
président du groupe en marche au sénat
céline boulay ce péronier bienvenue vous
êtes sénatrice de paris apparenté au
groupe et l'air patrick kanner bienvenue
à vous également sénateur du nord
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
avec nous également à distance thibaut
de la tocnaye bienvenue vous est
conseillé région
alors paca membre du bureau national du
rnd tête de liste dans le cher pour les
régionales et cendrars gaulle est
également avec nous bien venu vous êtes
secrétaire nationale adjointe d'europe
écologie les verts merci à tous les cinq
donc d'être avec nous pour cette
deuxième partie françois patriat
l'une des leçons à tirer de ce premier
tour c'est qu'il existe bien donc encore
une gauche et une droite en france c'est
ce que ça veut dire que finalement le
nouveau monde n'a pas encore
complètement balayées l'ancien monde
alors il existe surtout des équipes des
présidentes et les présidents sortants
qui avec leur réseau avec leur bilan
avec leur campagne longue puisqu'il
cette lan situation leur a permis de
garder leur implantation
la prime au sortant a joué plus que
d'habitude dans le contexte où nous
avons connu de prévacances de coheed de
période de baccalauréat peu propice
aujourd'hui inciter les gens à aller
voter
on a donc et ont donc été confortée
c'est une prime aux sortants qui a joué
à plein voilà c'est comme ça c'est comme
ça que j'explique ça veut pas dire que
nationalement il ya une bosse une droite
y avait des gens à planter chez les
républicains qui résistent bien et qui
sont en passe de gagner
il y avait des gens chez les socialistes
qui étaient mes amis à la roue c'est
particulier françois bonneau même
éventuellement je sais pas mais favre
est des gens qui étaient en situation de
tout cas carole delga c'est en situation
gagné qui font du très bon score au
premier tour parce que je crois que pour
les sortants ja lire la mise en garde et
la lutte contre l'extrême droite et le
récent mouvement national a profité en
sortant les gens se disant si vraiment
on veut pas du rassemblement national
autant voter pour les sortants tweets
qui risquent de gagner
donc victoire des sortants mais pas de
gauche et de droite spécial parce que la
gauche et la droite si on prend ainsi je
pense que fait le score d'alain rousset
le scot de najat vallaud-belkacem
vous voyez bien que c'est pas uniforme
je le saurai toi pourquoi je pose cette
question parce qu'on a à marc philippe
daubresse ici au sénat qui nous dit
enfin qu'il a confié à nos collègues de
publicsenat.fr l'opération de macron et
raté la bombe à fragmentation pour faire
exploser la droite ait raté céline
boulay speroni qu'en pensez vous oui
mais moi déjà une première réflexion je
ne suis pas d'accord
pardon avec le président patriat
non mais avec beaucoup de respect mais
la gauche et la droite sont toujours là
est bien présente
je n'en ai jamais douté pour moi ce sont
deux visions de la société qui
s'affrontent et parfois des
gestionnaires différend sur le terrain
et on a vu la tendance aux élections
régionales que c'est ce qui va était
bien vivant et que à force de vouloir
legault mais finalement finissez par
perturber notre électorat qui ne s'y
retrouvaient plus moi je crois vraiment
que la droite a eu un rôle à jouer et je
suis de droite j'ai toujours défendu des
idées de droite on avoue qu aux
municipales la droite avait fait
d'excellents scores dans les territoires
on voit qu aux régionales a fait
d'excellents scores à nouveau et et
voilà au sénat aussi elle montre sa
capacité à parler aux personnes à nos
concitoyens dans les problèmes concrets
du quotidien et vraiment je moi je suis
ravi de ce qui s'est passé je suis ravi
que la droite ait fait soit arrivé en
tête de ce scrutin
patrick hannais vous ai vu c'est parti
on l'a on l'a on l'a titré la revanche
de l'ancien monde point d'interrogation
est est ce que c'est un peu ce que vous
vous dites ce soit je bats trias estime
que la gauche et la droite c'est
toujours derrière nous et que l'avenir
que le nouveau monde c'est emmanuel
macron ce que je sais pas si c'est un
retour totalement réussie de la gauche
et la droite
en tout cas les résultats montrent que
nous aurons des élus à droite et à
gauche dans ces élections régionales
mais aussi départementale pas oublié par
contre ce que je sais c'est que ce sera
encore une fois un zéro pointé pour la
macro ni aux élections territoriales
après les municipales c'est le deuxième
zéro pointé donc mais qui ait pas de
malentendu réussir une élection pour la
gauche pour la droite au plan local ne
veut pas dire pour autant que le
maquereau ni disparaissent ça rassure à
monsieur patriat je pense qu emmanuel
macron représente je le dis souvent
finalement l'ensemble de ce que ce
mouvement est il est l'alpha et l'oméga
de macro ni il est la clé de voûte est
la voûte en même temps tout repose sur
lui tout repose sur lui et donc qu'il
vous faut riom une erreur à droite et à
gauche
nous qui sommes si mal en point au plan
national disons le très simplement de
penser que parce que nous avons eu des
résultats aux municipales des résultats
au départemental des résultats aux
régionales
eh bien naturellement les choses sur mes
traits d'aplomb aux élections nationales
qui arrive en fait maquereau et le pen
c'est pas le même combat
mais c'est la même logique tout repose
sur la personnalité de ses deux leaders
thibaut de la tocnaye vous êtes d'accord
avec cela écoutez en tout cas je
reprendrai un propos de monsieur patriat
c'est vrai que mais de manière très
honnête très objective ce set très
faible participation a évidemment
favorisé les sortants comme monsieur
bouquet madame pécresse ou monsieur
bertrand
mais ceci dit bon après une petite
déception je crois qu'il faut quand même
dédramatiser le rn est quand même en
deuxième position dans une majorité de
régions parfois proche du premier comme
en centre val de loire où nous sommes à
peine deux points
et puis on a une on nous sommes premiers
en provence alpes côte d'azur et je
pense que puisqu'on parle de nouveaux
mondes ne représentant aussi nous le
nouveau monde et au niveau des idées en
particulier car vous savez la sécurité
dans les transports dans les lycées où
la remise en cause de l'éolien c'est
nous et c'est repris par par un certain
nombre de deux président sortant de
région eux-mêmes
donc je crois que nous sommes bien là et
j'ai un autre point je pense que il ya
une constante également au niveau de l
air il ya toujours une bonne partie des
électeurs qui ont envie de voter pour
nous et je pense que comme dans beaucoup
de régions
nous sommes devant heller et bien il y
aura au deuxième tour un effet
d'entraînement vers nous et il y aura
non pas tous les électeurs mais partie
des électeurs de l air qui vont bien
voter pour nous deux
tours donc moi je suis finalement assez
confiant j'ai un peu le calme des
vieilles troupes car effectivement j'ai
été longtemps élu en paca et j'ai
déménagé en centre val de loire il
soutient alexandre à orly coli qui a
fait une très belle campagne et je pense
n'est pas jouée par exemple l'ensemble
val de loire voilà il va y avoir une
cadre angulaire et je pense que nous
pouvons peut-être tirer notre épingle du
jeu voilà donc tout n'est pas encore
écrit c'est ce que vous nous dites
comment vont les choses du côté d'europe
écologie les verts cendrars goal m'a dit
je n'ai pas perdu ma soirée parce que le
temps le rassemblement national nous
expliquer qu'ils étaient le nouveau
monde
je pense que ça vaut son pesant de
cacahuètes et que rien que pour ça cette
soirée voilà peine plus sérieusement
j'ai beaucoup d'échos j'espère que haye
pour vous à l'antenne parfait plus
sérieusement pour nous on reste comme
tout le monde marqué par cette
abstention qui non seulement se
structure mais devient de plus en plus
politique c'est à dire que là où il ya
quelques temps encore le vote
rassemblement national pouvait être un
vote de contestation a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui
et bien c'est l'abstention qui est elle
même un moyen de contestation
et ça c'est très inquiétant parce que ça
veut dire qu'on a tous tous les
politiques
un gros travail de remise en question à
faire de ce que l'on offre comme visage
je pense notamment à toutes les affaires
qui ont sali la vie politique de la
quasi totalité des partis représentés
sur votre plateau et à 10 ans et qui
altèrent le lien entre la société et les
politiques nous si vous me demandez le
prisme des écologistes je vais vous dire
que c'est plutôt positif puisque nous
doublons notre score fin ne faisant plus
que doubler notre score par rapport à
2015 c'est le score le plus élevé des
écologistes sur une élection régionale
ça ce double d'excellents résultats sur
les départementales également et ça
montre qu'après le succès des
européennes avait expliqué en mots que
c'était un fait du hasard après les
succès des municipales on nous avait dit
en gros c'est grâce aux qu'ovide ou la
photocopie comme vous vouliez est bien
là avec ces régionales l'écologie
démontra qu'elle est inscrite dans les
territoires qu'elle est réellement
inscrits dans la vie politique des
françaises et des français et que tu es
très loin du portrait du parti de bobos
il s'agit au contraire d'une nouvelle
poussée d'une demande qui émane
particulièrement des jeunes puisque même
s'ils sont très peu à s'être déplacés
les plus de 60% gens croient à des
jeunes qui se sont déplacés ont déclaré
voter pour les listes écologistes ce qui
dit beaucoup c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui arrive à faire se déplacer cet
électorat jeune dont on déplore qui nous
va pas voter ce sont les écologistes
il est peut-être là le nouveau monde a
construit françois patriat 109 rigole
par l'aide éventuelle remise en question
dans certains partis politiques est ce
qu'il y en aurait une en vue de la
présidentielle du côté d' en marche en
termes de stratégie évidemment est-ce
qu'il faut avoir une approche différente
en ce que je crois c'est que on peut pas
tirer de conclusion du travail d'une
élection locale a pu en tirer des
enseignements s'entend bien
je sais bien que patrick kanner excelle
dans l'art de dire du mal de la macro ni
de s'en prendre à elle toujours c'est
son exercice favori il le fait avec
talent je les écoute je l'entends chez
les éléments pour lui répond à dire
aujourd'hui par exemple faire du
triomphalisme au tour de cette élection
c'est tout à fait ça veut dire c'est une
élection quel local moi je me souviens
que dans le canton petit canton rural où
j'habitais jacques chirac faisait 70 %
au mois de mai je faisais tout seul 80%
au premier tour au mois d'octobre
cette voyelle élections locales n'a rien
à voir avec l'élection nationale donc on
le sait bien et moi je sais que les
français s'ils se sont désintéressés
c'est parce qu'aussi il pense maintenant
qu'il ya une élection mer que l'élection
majeure ces élections présidentielles et
que maison d'école un problème c'est que
tous les français de contrôle sur
l'élection avec eux tous à l'école je
suis de ceux qui regrettent aujourd'hui
d'avoir avec le nail jusqu'à participer
au décalage des élections législatives
derrière la présidentielle je pense
était ça a été une erreur je le dis
comme ça je reconnais c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je tente des
accords ensuite avec certains d'entre
nous met donc tirer des conclusions
aujourd'hui après tout on n'avait aucun
élu maire
dans les régions à nous maintenant nous
aurons des élus marcheurs madame rigole
qui qu'elle a doublé son score et sont
passés de trois et demi chez moi à addis
et bien non les déjà à 12 on existe
depuis trois ans depuis 20 ans alors je
vais pas faire un faux cocorico c'est
pas vrai pour nous cette élection est
une déception
c'est vrai parce que nous pensions faire
mieux nous pensions faire 15 ou la
question sur la remise en question par
vocation à l'élection présidentielle ne
doit pas être remise en question par une
élection locale
je crois que moi je n'ai pas de doute
sur l'année sur le sur l'année prochaine
je pense que le chef de l'état un socle
qui lui permettra je dirais peut-être
entre 23 et 28 qui lui permettra d'être
au deuxième tour l'année prochaine et
que ces élections locales n'influerait
en rien l'élection présidentielle
l'année prochaine donc pas de remise en
cause en tant que tel bien entendu
prendre en compte ce que disent les
parts les les électeurs j'ajoute que
pendant cette élection on a parlé de
tout sauf des régions céline boulay
speroni moi je dirais que tirer des
conclusions ce serait la dernière des
choses à faire
d'abord il ya un deuxième tour aux
régionales amputé après effectivement il
ya l'élection présidentielle le vote qui
a eu lieu hier qu'il aura lieu dans huit
jours ne présage peut-être pas de ce qui
va se passer aux présidentielles
peut-être coprésidence elle se sera
radicalement différent mais je note
plusieurs choses d'abord les sondages se
sont trompés
il ya peut-être une trop grande
importance des sondages dans l'élection
et dans la démocratie aujourd'hui il y
en a peut-être deux ou trois par jour
ils se trompent régulièrement maintenant
et c'est vrai que ça donne quand même
une photographie qui est intéressante
mais ça donne il faudrait offrir un
instant t et non pas une projection et
quelquefois le sondage crée aussi
l'opinion
peut-être un peu trop et induit les
français en erreur toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles les français n'ont pas
été votées hier doivent être analysées
avec beaucoup de précision par tous les
partis politiques notamment la vie ce
que je voudrais dire puisqu'on à
commencer par le fameux clivage gauche
droite c'est qu'on nous expliquait
depuis des semaines et des mois que ça y
est c'était jouer qu'il y avait un duel
qui était macron le pen
or les français n'ont pas voulu ils ont
montré hier pour ceux qui sont venus
voter
donc ça c'est quand même intéressant à
analyser il ne faut pas en tirer des
conclusions mais il faut il faut
absolument analysé parce que si les
français qui s'en servir de levier pour
ce qui est du signe vont plus voter
c'est parce qu'ils ont le sentiment de
ne plus être écoutés vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire donc il fut un temps je
ne dis pas que ça devrait être le cas
mais il fut un temps où des ministres
qui avait échoué il y en a quand même
cinq qui sont partis dans les hauts de
france démissionner les ministres de la
macro ni qui sont partis dans les hauts
de france est quand même eu quinze
ministres qu'on était en campagne
pendant ces élections régionales ils
sont allés soi disant pour faire chuter
le rassemblement national dans les hauts
de france
or on sait très bien que c'était une
supercherie puisque xavier bertrand n'en
avait pas besoin et qu'il a gagné et
qu'il a fait un score qui le met en
position d'être dans une dynamique qui
est quand même assez extraordinaire des
patients dieu très vite ce malade et il
a réussi ce pari de ce point de vue là
c'est à dire qu'il a inversé le score
qu'il avait par rapport au front
national
cinq ans auparavant et en plus de ça
pardon mais les ministres n'ont pas fait
non pas montrer voilà avec un laurent
preppy rachesky qui s'occupe d'ailleurs
de réforme des retraites en dessous de
10 donc je sais que la critique est
facile et l'art est difficile mais quand
même si on n'analyse pas très
précisément les choses les gens ont de
moins en moins voter et on est déjà à
70% d'abstention
jusqu'où irons-nous patrick nl et
ensuite on part voir quand et en paca
oui moi je voudrais rassurer
mon collègue françois austria jeu
je ne suis pas obsédé par la macro ni
pour moi j'ai comme deux adversaires en
tout cas ici adversaire que je respecte
la macro ni et la droite républicaine
qui d'ailleurs parfois se retrouve très
souvent même ça s'est fait avec le
résultat qu'on connaît en région paca et
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour dire que
les socialistes ont pesé de tout leur
poids pour le retrait de la liste portée
par ailleurs je crois que c'est
important de ne pas se tromper de combat
comme nous l'avions fait en 2015 dans la
même région mais aussi dans la région d
des hauts de france et sans aucun regret
mais je vois bien ce qui s'est passé
entre l'as raismes et la droite en
région paca je vois bien que monsieur
petrache hemsky première déclaration
hier après ce beau résultat dans les
autres en ce que vous avez souligné
qui dit mais j'appelle à voter xavier
bertrand la jambe gauche agents de
droite je vois surtout de jambe droite
finalement et c'est ça qui gêne le plus
d'ailleurs la droite républicaine c'est
que finalement elle se retrouve
concurrencé par un centre droit qui
n'ose pas dire son nom
finalement et la situation que j'ai vécu
moi de l'autre france le résume bien
c'était un problème entre la droite et
l'extrême droite et le centre-droit
voilà et les électeurs ont tranché nous
nous maintiendrons en tant que tel on a
évoqué l' abstention un mot quand même
ce qui n'a pas été pour l'instant
traiter cette affaire de
des professions de foi non arriver
j'espère qu'on va l'évoquer c'est un
fait pas un scandale d'état
mais c'est quand même un scandale dès
lors permettez qu'on y vienne juste
après on va d'abord aller quentin
qu'elle mais parce que l'une des régions
les plus incertaines dans cet entre deux
tours c'est effectivement la région paca
même si ce n'est pas la vague et rennes
annoncé le duel mariani muselier est
plus serré qu'attendu et le candidat de
la gauche écologiste est donc venu semer
un peu le trouble en confirmant son
maintien puis en le retirant peut-être
d'ailleurs après avoir été un peu
chahuté par europe ecologie les verts
cendrars gaulle nous en parlera dans un
instant voilà en tout cas qui rend la
région assez intéressante quand un calme
et à plus d'un titre vous êtes à
marseille avec olivier molinari qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire ce soir sur ce qui
joue surtout sur ce qui se joue sur
place pardon et bien c'est vrai mais
kaka est la situation de jean laurent
felice elle était devenue un
complètement intenable la pression sur
ses épaules était maximale depuis hier
avec les chefs de file de tous les
partis de gauche qui est appelée à son
retrait pour former un front républicain
alors il a réuni plus tôt dans la
journée tous ses colistiers toutes les
tendances ont pu prendre la parole à
tour de rôle la moitié d'entre eux
souhaitaient un maintien l'autre le
retrait certains ont fini en larmes à
cette réunion nous at on dit deux
inquiétudes nous ont raconté les
participants la peur de voir la région
bien sûr basculer dans le giron du rn
également l'idée d'être je cite cloué au
pilori par les médias est donc cet après
midi jean-laurent félicien a réuni et
les journalistes à son qg écouter le
candidat de la gauche en paca la défaite
de la haine et de l'intolérance n'est
pas certaine dans notre région
si nous nous maintenant je n'ai pas le
droit de jouer avec le feu prend il
vient que personne n'a plus de tête que
moi à vous lire et à vous le dire avec
insistance ce soir et on régionales
dimanche
je voterai pour renaud muselier pour
battre mariani et s'attriste courante
et donc ce retrait est un coup dur pour
thierry mariani le candidat soutenu par
le rassemblement national ce matin il
était ici d'ailleurs un à marseille il
rencontrait les journalistes sur le
vieux-port pas très loin d'ici jusqu'au
bout comme vous le voyez sur ces images
de juin attendu priest et de romane
boudy alors depuis hier le rn accuse le
coup on peut le dire ici en paca puisque
il était donné largement en tête et que
finalement il ne dispose que de cinq
points d'avancé sur la droite au premier
tour et donc jusqu'à cet après midi est
bien l idée que le candidat de la gauche
se maintiennent eh bien ça l'avantagé
nettement pluie mariani qui ne dispose
que de très peu de réserves de voix pour
le second tour
écoutez donc ce que disait le candidat
soutenu par le rn il énonçait ce matin
toute idée d'un front républicain
j'ai pas me prononcer sur le maintien ou
le retrait de monsieur félicien je dis
simplement que pour des personnes qui
votent à gauche c'est quand même
extraordinaire de leur dire aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya une sorte de mode ou de
conformisme idéologique qui s'est fait
depuis quelques années vous arrivez
troisième vous devez vous retirer je
vous rappelle que dans toutes les
élections jusqu'à présent quand on est
arrivé 3ème 4ème et qu'on avait de quoi
se maintenir
eh bien on essayé d'exister à la région
voilà
et donc ce soir le candidat soutenu par
le ray et rennes est en très mauvaise
position partie plus bas que marion
maréchal-le pen en 2015 il voit renaud
muselier en position de force bénéficier
de potentiel report de voix donc suite
au retrait du candidat de la gauche très
bien alors quand vous avez également
passé une partie de la journée avec
renaud muselier raconter non je suis
maître de mon destin
voilà ce que nous a dit renaud muselier
il dit être confortés sur toute la ligne
par sa stratégie politique
aujourd'hui on l'a suivi en déplacement
sur un site culturel à côté
d'aix-en-provence est venu parler d'art
visuel il a bien sûr été mitraillé de
questions uniquement politiques et
notamment sur le candidat de la gauche
un rapprochement est est il possible à
ce moment là entre les deux listes afin
de faire un front républicain
renaud muselier a botté en touche
écoutez quand on lui a demandé tout à
l'heure avec olivier molinari monsieur
muselier vous soyez pas votre téléphone
du tout là y'avait pas les des choses
qui se joue sur votre téléphone
peut-être regarder
regardez il doit se jouer sur mon plein
de choses et 250 messages
regardez regardez et donc aujourd'hui il
s'est agi de reprendre son slogan de
campagne ma région d'abord d'en faire
une réponse à beaucoup un des questions
justement un des journalistes renaud
muselier veut s'affranchir des logiques
de partie et aussi de toute pression
médiatique autour de l'élection il veut
alentours de maintenir il va avant tout
maintenir son cap
écoutez le seul message qui compte c'est
toujours le même jamais l'atteindre
je le répète je le martèle c'est pour ça
que ça finira bien
c'est notre région d'abord on n'est pas
des animaux de laboratoire n'est pas
bien si aujourd'hui vous avez eu un
premier tour qui conforme à ce que je
pensais c'est là qu'il ya une
reconnaissance du travail qui a été fait
les jeunes savent ils ont quand même
bonne mémoire ils sont pas stupides
voilà renaud muselier qui veut sortir
des logiques de partie alors mercredi on
attendait une visite ici de gérard
larcher de françois baroin ou encore de
christian jacob mais cette visite n'est
plus à l'ordre du jour l'équipe de
renaud muselier ne veut pas nationaliser
le scrutin
rebecca merci beaucoup quand un petit
bout de la tocnaye c'est un coup dur
pour le rassemblement national ce
retrait de jean laurent fait lydia et
coûté très franchement je suis quand
même pas né de la dernière pluie puisque
j'ai été longtemps élu en paca en
provence alpes côte d'azur
je m'attendais et nous nous attendions
un duel et voilà nous l'avons alors on
peut dire que la position de thierry
mariani n'est pas bonne enfin il est
quand même en tête par rapport à un
sortant
la plupart des présidents sortant et
l'air ou apparentés et l'air font plus
de 40 et il a cinq points d'avance et
vous savez il ya quelque chose qui
évoluent et les prises de conscience je
le redis encore une fois cette porosité
entre l air et les rues m et a fortiori
les socialistes et la gauche une partie
je ne dis pas tous les électeurs mais il
est évident qu'une bonne partie
et croyez moi je connais bien les
électeurs aient l'air de provence alpes
côte d'azur
il y en a une partie qui vont voter pour
thierry marié
et moi je vous dis franchement elle en
plus avec peut-être une mobilisation
deuxième tour qui peut rebattre les
cartes activement il est très possible
je le dis franchement honnêtement que
thierry mariani gagne au deuxième tour
il est en tête les gens voient bien
qu'il est en tête et ça c'est important
alors je voudrais juste en profiter pour
donner une autre réflexion à partir des
propos de monsieur patriat qui a dit
voilà nous on va pas gagner deux régions
mais grâce à la proportionnelle
nous allons avoir des élus et nous
allons pouvoir commencer à travailler
dans les régions eh bien moi je dis
pourquoi au niveau national on ne ferait
pas la même chose
je pense à une raison de la désaffection
des électeurs vis-à-vis du système
démocratique français c'est parce que
nous sommes le seul pays d'europe à ne
pas avoir de proportionnelle pour la
représentation nationale
alors ils s'inclinent une nouvelle si
vous le voulez bien thibaut de la
tocnaye en plus tournés vers cendres
ergols et peut-être qu'on abordera cette
question de la proportionnelle tout à
leurs cendres argol d'abord elle vous a
choqué cette hésitation du candidat jean
laurent fait lydia ou pas non elle est
naturelle quand on s'est battu pour
proposer d'autres idées d'autres valeurs
dans une région où par ailleurs la
nature et particulièrement malmenés ou
la pauvreté grimpa etc
c'est normal de se dire on peut pas
abandonner on peut pas abandonner les
gens qui ont voté pour nous on ne peut
pas abandonner cet espoir pour autant le
choix qui a été fait j'ai bien entendu
autres lancements ou lui disiez que nous
avions nous depuis paris beaucoup
beaucoup appuyé pour ce retrait c'est un
fait quelque chose qui a été réfléchie
entre candidats et candidates dans le
sud en paca et c'est un simple qu'ils
ont choisi de prendre une option qui
leur semblait la plus éthique et la plus
conforme à leurs valeurs alors c'est
patrick kanner il me semble qu ils
disaient qu'ils avaient beaucoup aux
craintes du côté du parti socialiste on
avait en tout cas beaucoup appuyé pour
que
ça se fasse oui j'ai je pense que les
appareils parisiens comme on dit souvent
ont pris leurs responsabilités vous
savez moi j'ai fini si les hauts de
france donc je sais ce que ça veut dire
que de se retirer on a payé pour pour
savoir depuis six ans dans cette région
et je mesure que la région paca 12 ans
sans la gauche
c'est une anomalie démocratique c'est
même un déni démocratique pour des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont fait confiance à la liste qui a été
ainsi portée par les socialistes et les
verts les verts les socialistes donc
mais voilà il n'y avait pas de choix je
pense que quand il ya un danger
prenationale réel ce qui est le cas en
région paca
je pourrais aussi le dire à mon collègue
patriat il va croire que je lui en veux
mais en région bourgogne franche comté
en jaune bourgogne franche comté
très honnêtement il ya peut-être un
risque moindre mis un risque front
national et on aurait pu imaginer que la
liste de la raim se retire pour
permettre à marc guide du fait de
pouvoir totalement être certaine de
gagner ce qui n'est pas encore le cas
dont je le regrette je le dis au passage
éclair en tout cas là il n'est pas
complet enfin il est en souffrance de la
gauche est exemplaire
quand on fait appel à elle pour se
battre et pour empêcher l'arrivée du
front national je dis bien le front
national aux responsabilités
essentielles dans nos régions sans sa
patrie a déboursé pas toujours vrai je
me souviens qu'en lorraine une fois la
dernière fois et socialistes étaient
maintenus alors qu'il avait un très très
gros risques front national oui pourtant
de les contrôler avec contre l'avis du
national matimov assurés sociaux
masseret qui est un ami jean pierre
masseret qui l'a fait je ne lui je lui
en voulais par non ce que je veux dire c
est y at-il un risque pour une franche
comté pour répondre à la question de
patrick kanner d'abord qui vient d'une
région
quand je vois aujourd'hui où elle parti
socialiste et la gauche unie dans les
hauts de france et en paca région qu'ils
ont dirigé pendant des dizaines d'années
c'est pas de la faute à emmanuel macron
s'ils en sont là aujourd'hui te
concernant la bouche de la charité que
je manquais l'hôpital
il existait pas il ya trois ans c'est
aujourd'hui ont fait 12 alors elle est
pas mal bon alors pour les élections
locales fera beaucoup mieux l'année
prochaine
en bourgogne franche-comté marie-guite
dufay fait 26 salles est en tête lcl
s'est allié avec les verts lisant
qu'elle préférait donner et huit sièges
aux communistes que de parler avec nous
c'est son choix que l'avons respecté
nous en tirerons les conséquences
26 plus 10 36 plus encore le temps des
cerises qui fait qu'un pas elle a 40 %
des voix le front national est à 22
il n'a pas de réserve de voix monsieur
platret est à côté et partagent donc il
n'y a aucun risque le front national est
ce que je peux dire d'ailleurs
autant je déplore l'abstention autant je
me réjouis
ce que je peux dire ce soir on voit
qu'il n'y aura aucun élu d'extrême
droite dans aucune région française et
je rappelle quand même que sous monsieur
hollande et souviens-tu sarkozy perd
d'ailleurs nommé président parle de
crise
bon très bien aucune président et
dernière chose à faire un vieux
provoquer un peu patrick kanner j'aime
bien me battre
sous monsieur hollande que j'ai aidé et
soutenu et sous monsieur sarkozy le
front national était à 30
sous monsieur macron il est à 22 ce qui
prouve que mâcon a raison d'avoir
désigné le front national est le point
commun comme un comme l'adversaire de
lutter contre lui c'est quand même mieux
que sous les kanaks précédent céline
boulay speroni ensuite on parle des
dysfonctionnements rebondir sur le front
national on se réjouit à juste titre
qu'ils aient reculé par rapport aux
prises d'abord par rapport aux
régionales 10 à 5 ans et par rapport aux
prévisions des sondeurs c'est quand même
la deuxième force politique en france
moi je ne m'en contente pas donc je me
battrai vraiment jusqu'aux
présidentielles et bien au delà pour que
le front national n'y soit pas et pardon
de revenir à xavier bertrand mais qui
s'impose aujourd'hui comme étant un
rempart vis-à-vis du front national avec
ce qu'il a fait dans sa région en
rempart contre le front national
ce qui a fait 1 sa région l'autre chose
pour parler de la région paca mais ce
livre visiblement sa stratégie a quand
même payer quand on voit les résultats
aujourd'hui
et pourtant dieu sait s'il a essuyé un
tir de barrage on parle beaucoup de la
violence en politique en ce moment mais
lui il en a eu son lot et puis troisième
réflexion
la politique c'est pas des additions
c'est à dire je me retire et puis les
votes sa division
et là c'est le monsieur filiz ayan
candidats élevé bon il ya beaucoup de
mères qui à droite et notamment monsieur
musulin sur la région ont d un bilan en
matière écologique on discute du projet
de loi en matière écologique aujourd'hui
au sénat et la droite veut faire
beaucoup d'amendements et de proposition
en ce sens donc il faut se garder aussi
quand on parle de l'abstention de
préempter les sujets en disant tel sujet
appartient telles formations politiques
publiques quand ce n'est pas vrai parce
que voilà on a dit lin blanc dans toutes
les formations politiques notamment en
matière d'écologie mais il faut toujours
aller plus loin bien entendu aller à
bordeaux cette question du
dysfonctionnement qui s'est donc produit
dans la distribution des tracts la
commission des lois du sénat a décidé
d'entendre gérald darmanin sur le sujet
ce mercredi vous pourrez d'ailleurs
suivre cette audition sur notre antenne
dès 8 heures ce mercredi le ministère de
l'intérieur était informé depuis
plusieurs jours des problèmes
d'acheminement des documents de
propagande électorale
il est urgent de remédier à ce
dysfonctionnement pour le second tour
c'est ce que nous dit françois noël
buffet qui est donc le président de
cette commission des lois patrick kanner
puisque vous avez vous abordé cet sujet
ce sujet vous y voyez un grave
dysfonctionnement
oui un grave dysfonctionnement pour
notre démocratie qui n'est pas le seul
d'ailleurs je me permets de rappeler que
beaucoup d'entre nous avons reçu les
professions de foi pour le départemental
il y a plus un mois maintenant avant
même que la campagne officielle soit
lancé et donc beaucoup de personnes ont
dû oublier ou ont dû ranger quelque part
ces professions de foi en général elles
arrivent dans la dernière semaine c'est
à dire au moment où les choses
commencent à devenir un peu n'ont pas
sérieusement tout cas plus les plus
tangente possible là on a vu des des
professions de foi brûlé
et dentelle dans telle région enfin
c'est un scandale absolu on serait dans
un pays anglo saxon un ministre de
l'intérieur en tout cas le ministre en
charge qui le font à l'intérieur ou un
autre ne serait pas coupable mais
responsable et aurait démissionné parce
que des millions de français et non pas
21000 français comme j'ai pu l'entendre
de la bouche de l'adjointe de monsieur
d'arman à savoir la fia bas 21 millions
des millions tout à l'heure j'ai
tellement une réunion de travail avec
mon équipe j'ai posé la question de
gestion 5 lors de la table convient
avaient réussi leur profession de foi de
2 sur sur cinq c'est pas un sondage je
vous le concède mais les services n'ont
pas été à la hauteur donc le ministère
n'a pas été à la hauteur
je pense que c'est une très très graves
dysfonctionnements encore une fois qu'il
faut en tirer les conséquences et pas
uniquement en retirant le marché à
l'entreprise nous avons sinon sa beauté
mot est un peu fort je vous le concède
mais en tout cas nous avons diminué
potentiellement l'impact que
représentent les professions de foi
parce que pour beaucoup de personnes
c'est le seul document qu'elle reçoive à
l'occasion d'une campagne électorale
donc il ya une faute une faute de l'état
il faut des responsables de l'état qui
ne peut pas se limiter uniquement à la
remise en cause d'un marché utilisent le
service public et notamment le fait
public qui était assurée pendant
longtemps par les mairies était bien
plus à la hauteur de ce que nous avons
vécu ici pendant cette élection
vous vouliez intervenir c'est juste pour
dire que je suis totalement d'accord
avec ce que ce cas n'est revient de dire
surtout dans un contexte où les français
sortait de la crise
on peine souvent à savoir à quoi sert
une région un département quels en sont
les contenus oui l audition de gérald
darmanin et oui à une commission
denquête ou pas c'est ce que devant
jean-luc mélenchon oui ça pourrait
savourer ça pourrait absolument seul
enquête parlementaire sur le sujet ça
pourrait tout à fait
oui j'ai pour une coupe sur l' enquête
au niveau du sénat c'est un problème qui
est grave et
oui qui a entravé probablement ça votre
françois patriat bon d'abord non mais
nous sommes les premières victimes
moi même les portions des documents
beaucoup de mes voisins n'ont pas reçu
et dérogeant arrivés dans les bureaux de
vote en dix ans et qui pour qui c'est
quoi pourquoi ces cantonales se
connaissaient pas qu'on leur disait mon
club mon candidat c'est monsieur curio à
bon c'est vraiment on connait pas ils
savaient pas connaissais pas donc ceux
qui n'avaient pas la notoriété puisque
les gens qui votaient pour madame
pécresse pas posé la question il venait
voter madame pécresse
il savait madame pécresse retourner
voter en franche comté
denis therriault les gens donc vous
donner les premières victimes ceux qui
n'avaient pas la notoriété et que ce qui
n'était pas sourd temps donc je déplore
avec vous cette fête je le trouve
inacceptable je prends le ministre l'a
dénoncé il a convoqué aujourd'hui les
deux opérateurs
il y aura des sanctions il y aura des
mesures qui seront prises par les
commissions d'enquêté au sénat on aime
bien les amendements les conditions des
enquêtes
donc on aime bien ça alors ça on adore
ça comme dit mon ami jean-pierre sueur
c'est l'air que nous respirons alors
très bien alors respirons allons-y pour
une commission d'enquêté
le projet de marco boue comme passion de
co2 qu'elle n'améliorerait pas là bon
c'est comme ça c'est ma décision
son art gold vous vous seriez pour une
commission d'enquêté est une commission
d enquête mais surtout se poser des
questions sur cette faculté que l'on a à
précariser le travail ce sont
effectivement des travailleurs d'être
des personnes qui est à distribuer ces
documents dans des entreprises privées
ou en tant que prestataire qui sont très
mal payés et qu'ils se débarrassent des
des professions de foi enfin des paquets
de l'envelope au lieu de les distribuer
parce que ça permet de livrer plus
rapidement d'autres payer un peu mieux
etc
ces problèmes c'est à dire qu'on a
dévalorisé notre travail et à partir de
ce travail en tout cas et à partir du
moment où le dévalorise on se retrouve
dans la situation actuelle il ya certes
en défaut de surveillance de l'état qui
en train d'essayer de leur mort ap
mais il ya aussi un problème beaucoup
plus de fonds qui est qu à précariser
nôtre
on se retrouve dans une situation qui
commence à haïti où on a vu par exemple
mais tous les partis concernés encore
les affiches installées sur les arts
d'eau sur les murs parce que les
personnes chargées les affiches et
considéré que ça faisait un trop grand
détour dans les villages de montagne
voyez tout ça c'est un travail qui
s'accélère qui est de plus en plus
précaire et mon âme au delà de la
question de la commune font enquête
une vraie question à se poser sur le
modèle que l'on construit les rondes aux
ânes
thibaut de la tocnaye oui je voudrais
dire que c'est quand même une rente pour
le fonctionnement de nos institutions il
ya un mot qui a été prononcé mais pour
le dire clairement
moi je suis un défenseur de l'entreprise
privée j'ai dirigé toute ma vie des
entreprises dont j'ai créé les dernières
la privatisation des services publics et
de cette distribution des documents
officiels est un scandale et ça va tout
à fait dans le sens de la folie des
privatisations de monsieur macron encore
une fois je suis pour la défense de
l'entreprise privée d'ailleurs les
régions un gros rôle à jouer pour
défendre les pmi etc
nous avons beaucoup de propositions dans
ce domaine mais nous voulons défendre
également parallèlement les services
publics et en particulier en ruralité et
ça c'est c'est vraiment une volonté de
détricoter ce qui a fait la grandeur de
la france la grandeur du service de
l'état
c'est une honte et c'est ce mot de
privatisation des services publics qui
est ça renvoie à ça et ça nous nous y
opposons formule trouve alors un tout
petit mot si vous voulez bien on ferme
ce chapitre est on vraiment il nous
reste quelques minutes sur les questions
de l'abstention parce que plus que le
chiffre je voudrais vous lire ces
témoignages qui sont parues dans le
monde cet après midi pierre 25 ans
encarté au modem au bureau de vote à
lille dans les hauts-de-seine qui nous
dit il n'y a pas de volontaires il n'y a
pas de scrutateurs il n'y a pas de
citoyens pour venir voter on n'a rien si
avec ça on ne comprend pas qu'il y a un
problème
trois points de suspension deuxième
témoignage patrick ouvrier retraité de
69 ans inscrits à nogent sur seine dans
le grand est qui nous dit les français
sont de grands gueulard mais ils ne
votent pas le vote devrait être
obligatoire et je voudrais un dernier
tour de table assez rapide si vous le
pouvez évidemment sur cette question
la lueur des chiffres de l'abstention
faut-il rendre ce vote obligatoire
patrick anr non jeu honnêtement je crois
à la conviction pas la contrainte
par contre notre démocratie est en crise
il ya des moyens très simples dames de
l'améliorer le vote par correspondance
que nous défendons dans cette haute
assemblée depuis longtemps à mon avis
est une chose évidente
voilà c'est ce n'est pas la solution
mais c'est un élément de solution ça a
été refusé par la part le gouvernement
refusait aussi par nos collègues de
droite je le regrette parce que vraiment
c'est une manière d'améliorer les choses
mais la vraie question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est le sens finalement du
vote à quoi ça sert et est ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
français qui parfois même voté front
national
la limite pour dire non mais qui vont
plus même au niveau plus ce qui signifie
très très concrètement que nous sommes
tous interpellés sur comment améliorer
le fonctionnement démocratique dans un
pays comme le nôtre la 5e un public à
mon avis est arrivé à une forme de
saturation en la matière il faudra y
réfléchir non pas de changer de
république mais peut-être d'améliorer
les choses à démocratie participative la
démocratie collaborative doit être plus
mis en avant pour mieux remobiliser nos
électeurs et pardon il nous reste deux
minutes
rapidement c'est les boules moi je suis
certaine que si les français vont moins
voter c'est de la faute des partis
politiques donc on ne pourrait envisager
de le rendre obligatoire et je ne suis
absolument pas pour cette solution
d'accord que si on s'était vraiment
poser toutes les questions de savoir
pourquoi ils ne vont plus voter
est-ce que c'est l'obsession tactique
qu'il est qu'il est qu'il est qui les
éloigne des urnes
est ce que est ce que c'est parce qu'ils
ont l'impression d'être moins
représentés il ya une crise de
l'engagement certes due aux politiques
il faut d'abord essayer de la comprendre
avant d'envisager des solutions
radicales mais je ne suis pas pour
celle-là
sandra rigole les françaises et les
français engagent il s'engage dans la
vie civique ils s'engagent à travers les
associations à travers les ong notamment
les hadjis environnementale donc le
défaut n'est pas dans la méthode de
votre que l'on propose mais bien dans le
fond c'est à dire quel projet politique
pour une part et d'autre part
quelle est la transparence et l'éthique
quelle est la confiance que nos
concitoyens et concitoyennes peuvent
avoir dans la vie politique quand on
voit que la totalité des parties
présentes sur votre plateau à
l'exception du mien ont eu affaire à des
affaires qui ont défrayé la chronique et
l'argent public
thibaut de la tocnaye en 30 secondes
pardonnez moi oui une dernière idée très
concrète
nous sommes les premiers à avoir demandé
à l'institution des référendums
d'initiative populaire voilà une autre
manière et bien de finalement de
redonner envie à nos concitoyens de
participer à la vie politique
voilà il mettait la proportionnelle au
niveau national et vous allez voir que
tout d'un coup et bien y avoir une
participation beaucoup plus importante
françois patriat même consiste bien
sinon mais le vote c'est comme la
vaccination obligatoire opa obligatoire
la contrainte ça fonctionne pas vraiment
et ce n'est pas souhaitable
par contre on dit avec votre passé à
cause des partis politiques
moi je ne connais pas de démocratie qui
fonctionne sans parti politique
faudrait-il supprimer les parties pour
que les gens aillent voter je ne le
crois pas non quand on va voir les gens
venir j'interrogeais des gens dans les
bureaux électoraux le musée moi j'ai pas
voté que ça va rien changer leur coton
leur prend exemple par exemple ce que la
vie politique a changé depuis des
dizaines d'années est-ce que ça n'a rien
changé la vie politique regardez
aujourd'hui en matière de santé en
matière d'école si ça change les choses
donc je crois que et que ce sont ceux
dont je convaincu c'est que l'année
prochaine pour l'élection majeure on
repassera au dessus des 60 millions de
palettes mais ce serait l'occasion de
rethel c'est çà comme çà on choisit
voteront pour la présidentielle parce
que pour eux il ya un an je mange et on
s'arrêtera là merci infiniment à tous
les cinq d'avoir participé à cette
édition spéciale d'al en plus loin on se
retrouve demain à 18 heures et à 22h30
dans un instant auditions publiques
plusieurs invités politiques ce soir
philippe ballard pour le rassemblement
national coralie dubost pour la
république en marche rémi féraud pour le
parti socialiste et guillaume
ethier pour le parti l air demain 7h30
bonjour chez vous avec au rayonnement de
fini et ses invités également excellente
soirée sur public sénat